good evening everyone my name is Andres
Golding I'm the music buyer here at
politics and prose very very happy
delighted thrilled that we got to do
this event tonight I finished the book
just recently I loved every minute of it
there's a lot of wonderful testimony all
throughout the book by musicians who
were transformed their lives were
changed and by listening and hearing
Louis Armstrong and that's a running
theme throughout the book there their
book is just marvelous
in expressing what Louis was able to do
in a radical way and how his career was
just so fused with this love that is
palpable that comes jumping out at you
when you hear his music every jazz fan
comes into jazz via song or an artist or
an album it's all different but sooner
or later you do get back to Louis mm-hmm
I came through miles listening to Miles
Don Cherry Lester Bowie
but eventually I did get to Louis I was
staying in France for a little while
and I heard a show called sweet let em
it was for an hour they played the same
song different versions in chronological
order and you really got to see what
jazz musicians did with a song they
always went in chronological order and
the first song you heard was always the
stiffest original cast recording from
broadway play that was probably in the
french archives nowhere else and
oftentimes Louis
Armstrong would record one of the
earliest versions of a song when you
heard the difference between that
original kind of plotting version and
then the radical musicality joy again
inventiveness lyricism it really brought
tears to your eyes and really made you
understand what jazz is and carroty
shout conveys this all throughout this
book I'm going to just bring him on and
we're going to have two video clips we
have some audio we're going to have some
music afterwards during the signing for
the Q&A please come to the mic over
there so the c-span audiences can hear
your question and please without further
ado please help me welcome Terry
Teachout well thank you very much this
is this has been a big couple of days
for me yesterday I found out point that
right at me yesterday I found out that
Pop's had been nominated for an N double
ACP Image Award and about 10 minutes
after that I found out that it was going
on to the New York Times best seller
list next week so Mazel Tov indeed I had
to brag about that it's it's a wonderful
thing to be here I'm delighted to be
here and I am delighted to be talking
about a man who was well delightful you
can say a lot of things about Louis
Armstrong which obviously is why I wrote
a book about him but if you have the
good fortune to speak to anyone who knew
him personally be it casually or
intimately you can bet that they'll all
tell you the same thing he was a truly
lovable man now I spent most of my life
in the company of artists and one thing
I can tell you is that the greatest ones
10
not to be especially lovable likeable
yes sometimes charismatic yes sometimes
and not infrequently irresistible for
it's part of human nature for us
ordinary people to want to warm our
hands of the fire of a Great Creator but
those fires are very hot indeed
and I've known any number of people who
got badly burned as a result of keeping
company with greatness now Louis
Armstrong was different he was a great
man who was also a good man kind and
generous and considerate and unlike many
good men he wasn't even slightly boring
he was utterly unpretentious he didn't
talk in pompous cliches
he loved to laugh and he knew how to
make other people laugh and on top of
all that he was the greatest jazz
musician who ever lived
Armstrong was one of the cultural Giants
of the 20th century America has never
produced a more significant artist I
ranked him right alongside Aaron Copland
and Robert Frost and Frank Lloyd Wright
but unlike those men he was also a great
entertainer whose music was and is loved
by ordinary people all over the world in
1964 he actually knocked the Beatles off
the top of the pop charts with his
recording of Hello Dolly Aaron Copeland
never did that you can see why I was
drawn to the idea of writing the
biography is so singular a creature as
Satchmo or pops as his friends called
him now needless to say I'm not the
first person to have done so but I am
the first biographer to have had access
to six hundred and fifty reel-to-reel
tapes that Armstrong made during the
last quarter-century of his life many of
which contain astonishingly candid
recordings of his private after-hours
conversations Armstrong switched on his
tape recorder whenever the spirit moved
him and so you can hear him chatting
with friends over dinner getting high
with an old pal in his dressing room
after a show even trying to coax his
wife into bed
five in the morning for a little
hanky-panky not only did these tapes
shine a bright light on his personality
which was far more complex than most
people realize but they also make it
possible for us to know the full stories
of such key moments in his life as his
1930 marijuana arrest that's a big part
of what made me want to write Pop's
nowadays most folks know me as a drama
critic I'm the drama critic of The Wall
Street Journal but I'm also a trained
musician the first one in fact ever to
write a fully sourced Armstrong
biography I started out as a
professional jazz musician a bass player
before becoming a full-time writer that
experience I believe has helped me to
understand Armstrong's music and the
world in which he lived and worked from
the inside out in pops I've tried to
translate that knowledge into plain
English and weave it into the incredible
story of Armstrong's life as Duke
Ellington said he was born poor died
rich and never heard any one on the way
but how did he work that miracle in the
course of writing Pop's I came to feel
that Armstrong's triumph was as much a
function of his personality as of his
musical genius if you don't understand
the one you won't understand the other
and it is Armstrong's personality to
which I want to introduce you now so let
us start in the best possible way by
watching him at work you know I've been
playing that clip from coast-to-coast
and every time I do everybody claps that
is the Louis Armstrong who took the
world by storm in the 20s and 30s the
public Armstrong and pops I take you
backstage to meet the private Armstrong
for there is more to Louis Armstrong
much more than most people know though
he was known the world over for his
million volts mile Armstrong was a
tough-minded
realistic man who always knew the score
whether it was about race relations or
the music business or anything else he
loved to tell tales about his life and
he told them very very well for he was
not just a gift
musician but a gifted writer Tallulah
Bankhead one of his biggest fans said
that he uses words like he strings notes
together artistically and vividly
armstrong strung his words together very
neatly indeed when he told the story of
his encounter with a gun-toting Chicago
gangster in 1931 he was working at a
mobbed-up nightclub called the showboat
when what he described as a big badass
hood
named Frankie Foster came backstage
after the show and told him that he
would be playing in New York City the
next night Armstrong said he already had
a gig in Chicago Foster pulled his
pistol and cocked it here's how
Armstrong described what happened next
Jesus had looked like a cannon and sound
like death so I looked down at that
steel and say well maybe I do open in
New York tomorrow I tried to get that
side of pops of Armstrong into the tops
too because it's as much a part of his
genius as anything else Joe Glaser his
manager once said that Armstrong was a
real real man he reminds me of something
that my namesake the Roman playwright
Terrance wrote 2,000 years ago I am a
man and nothing is alien to me Louis
Armstrong was a real man and nothing was
alien to him and he turned it all good
and bad into music now I'm going to read
you part of the prologue to pops in
which I try to convey Armstrong's
personality in words so now an excerpt
from Pop's a life of Louis Armstrong it
goes without saying or should that Louis
Armstrong's music was the most important
thing about him yet his personal story
in addition to shedding light on the
Wellsprings of his art is important in
its own right and no less in need of a
historically aware interpretation he was
a child of his time not ours and some of
the things he did and said as an adult
are barely intelligible to those who
know little of the world of his youth
even in his own time he was widely
misunderstood often by people who should
have known better to understand him now
we must see him as he was a black man
born at the turn of the century in the
poorest quarter of New Orleans who by
the end of his life was known and loved
in every corner of the earth what manner
of man succeeded in making so amazing a
journey how did he rise above the
unforgiving circumstances of his birth
to become a culture shaping giant and
what marks did those circumstances leave
on him everyone who knew Armstrong
agreed that he was what he seemed to be
what you saw was what you got said Joe
Marini who played clarinet in his band
the All Stars Jack Bradley a
photographer whom Armstrong befriended
in the 60s described him as
down-to-earth natural completely
unpretentious simple in the best sense
of the word it was his genuineness as
much as his genius to which his fans
responded he once reacted to a radio
interviewers pronouncement that he was a
living American legend by dropping his
pants and giggling I don't care what
company I'm in what environment you know
he said on another occasion I just want
to be there and enjoy it
just as good as the average cat whether
on stage or off he was the embodiment of
Johnny Mercer's admonition in accentuate
the positive you've got to spread joy up
to the maximum keep bloom down to the
minimum Danny Barker the New Orleans
guitarist saw him in his dressing room
after a show and remembered the side
Everafter
Barker wrote he'd be sitting down in his
underwear with a towel round his lap one
around his shoulders and that white
handkerchief on his head and he put that
grease around his lips look like a
minstrel man you know and laughing you
know natural the way he is and in the
room you see maybe two nuns you see a
streetwalker dressed all up in flaming
clothes you see maybe a guy come out of
the Penn State Penitentiary you see
maybe a blind man sitting there you see
a rabbi
you see a priest si liable to see maybe
two policemen are detectives see you see
a judge all of them different levels of
society in the dressing room and he's
talking to all of them
and there'll be some kids there white
and colored all the diverse people
different social levels and everybody's
looking got their eyes dead on him just
like they was looking at a diamond he
was of course the least average of cats
though his place in the history of jazz
is harder to explain than is commonly
understood Armstrong did not invent jazz
nor was he its first significant figure
and it's not even right to call him the
first great jazz soloist as many critics
and scholars have done Sidney Bechet the
New Orleans clarinetist who was four
years his senior preceded him by a
decade while Bix Beiderbecke started
winning national recognition at the same
time as Armstrong almost to the month
what then made Louis Armstrong standout
and why is his name still known to those
who know nothing else about jazz the
simplest explanation and up to a point
the best one is that he was the first
great influence in jazz no sooner did he
burst upon the scene than other
musicians trumpeters saxophonist singers
started imitating him I tried to walk
like him talk like him eat like him
sleep like him said Rex Stewart who
replaced Armstrong in Fletcher
Henderson's band Coleman Hawkins
Henderson's star saxophonist heard him
for the first time in 1924 and was
stunned into speechlessness he
remembered I stood silent feeling almost
bashful asking myself if I would ever be
able to attain a small part of Louis
Armstrong's greatness the trumpeter max
Kaminsky told of how the combination of
Lewis's dazzling virtuosity and
sensational brilliance of tone so
overwhelmed me that I felt as if I had
stared into the sun's eye such imagery
can easily - those who heard Armstrong
in his halcyon days the poet Philip
Larkin a part-time jazz critic
the lifelong fan praised him in similar
terms calling him something
inexhaustible and unchanging like the
Sun even Miles Davis who loathed
Armstrong's clowning knew that the
history of jazz radiated outward from
the bell of his horn he said you can't
play nothing on trumpet that doesn't
come from him I can't even remember a
time when he sounded bad playing the
trumpet
never what spoke to these artists as it
speaks to all those hearing Armstrong
for the first time is the combination of
hurtling momentum and expansive lyricism
that propelled his playing and singing
alike the four staccato quarter notes
that he raps out at the start of West
End blues his most celebrated recording
proclaimed the coming of a new way of
thinking about rhythm though the passage
looks innocuous on paper it catapulted
his fellow Jasmine into a musical world
in which even the simplest of phrases
were charged with an irresistible
forward thrust to be sure his internal
metronome was exact enough to impress
the most fanatically rhythm at achill of
classical musicians Herbert von carry on
once told the members of the Vienna Farm
on it
that he was going to an all-stars
concert imagine he said two hours of
music and never once will it slow down
or speed up by mistake but Armstrong
could also toy with time stretching it
this way and that as he does in the
serene trumpet solo that ends his 1933
recording of Harold Arlen's I got a
right to sing the blues hovering miles
above the clockwork tyranny of the beat
and sounding for all the world like a
lordly turn-of-the-century Grand Opera
tenor the comparison is apt for
Armstrong liked listened to and learned
from opera I like that deep stuff also
it guesses me to no end
he told Orson Welles late in life he
remembered buying his first record
player a wind-up Victrola as a teenager
in New Orleans he said most of my
records were the original Dixie
and jazz band but I had Caruso too and
Henry Bergh Gallacher Chi Tetrazzini
they were all my favorites then there
was the Irish tenor John McCormack
beautiful phrasing but his style was
also permeated with the rough beauty of
the blues and if it was his way to sing
and play them with a smile he knew as
well as anyone that the world of which
he sang could be a hurtful place he said
like when I play maybe back at town
blues I'm thinking about one of the old
lowdown moments when maybe your woman
didn't treat you right at the hell of a
moment when a woman tell you I got
another mule in my stole even the
classical melodies he loved took on a
new tint when passed through the prism
of his vast experience I seen everything
from a child coming up he said nothing
happened I ain't never seen before he
was forever reflecting on the things he
had seen sometimes on paper but more
often with his horn he wrote when I blow
I think of times and things from out of
the past that gives me an image of the
tune like moving pictures passing in
front of my eyes a town a chick
somewhere back down the line an old man
with no name you seen once in a place
you don't remember that was why he never
used musical terminology when speaking
of his music it was all about life these
are but a few of the myriad facets of
Armstrong's art and one can go a long
way toward understanding him without
mentioning anything else but it is not
enough to declare him a phenomenally
gifted and imaginative artist and let it
go about the other reason why he casts
so long a shadow is that his personality
was as compelling as his artistry the
two could scarcely be separated for his
lavish generosity of spirit was part and
parcel of his prodigal way of making
music even in his old age he held
nothing back and it seemed at times that
nothing was beyond him he really did
perform with everyone from
Bernstein to Johnny Cash he really did
end his concerts some of them anyway
by playing 250 or more high C's capped
with a high F he wrote the finest of all
jazz autobiographies Satchmo my life in
New Orleans without a collaborator the
ranks of his admirers included Kingsley
Amos Jackson [ __ ] Jean Renoir Lou
Courvoisier the composer Virgil Thompson
called him a master of musical art
Stuart Davis whose abstract paintings
were full of jazz inspired images cited
him as a model of greatness is it any
wonder then that so many musicians
longed to play the way he played and
sing the way he sang it was no accident
that they usually referred to Armstrong
not as Satchmo his own favorite nickname
but his pops he was the father figure of
jazz and what his children wanted was to
be him or at least come as close as they
possibly could why did Armstrong spend
so many hours scribbling on a pad or
hunched over a typewriter partly because
he was a gregarious man who enjoyed
sending chatty letters to his friends
and fans we actually have a gentleman in
the audience tonight
who has a couple of letters that
Armstrong sent him but also because he
believed that he had something of value
to tell the world having been born
desperately poor he had worked
desperately hard first as a boy and then
as a man in this he had much in common
with ragged dick
horatio alger 'he's plucky bootblack
whose burning desire to grow up
respectable propelled him into the ranks
of the middle class self-discipline
self-improvement self-reliance
these were Armstrong's lifelong
watchwords
and no Horatio Alger hero could have
improved on his iron determination to
get ahead in the world once he did so he
felt an obligation to tell others how to
do the same I was determined to play my
horn
against all odds and I had to sacrifice
a whole
lot of pleasure to do so he wrote in
Satchmo a few years later he made the
point more pungently in a TV interview
in which he said the Lord will help the
poor but not the poor lazy
while most jazz musicians black and
white alike now come from relatively
comfortable backgrounds those who are
born poor have almost always striven
mightily to join the middle class anyone
who doubts that Armstrong filled the
letter bill need only visit his home
located seven blocks from Shea Stadium
in a run-down but respectable part of
Queens it is a pre story brick covered
frame house whose interior is
reminiscent of Graceland Elvis Presley's
gaudy Memphis mansion from the Jetsons
style kitchen of the future to the
silver wallpaper in gold and faucets of
the master bathroom the Armstrong house
looks like what it is the residence of a
poor boy who cast down his bucket and
pulled it up overflowing unlike
Graceland though the house is neither
oppressive nor embarrassing and as you
stand in the smallish study whose
decorations include a portrait of the
artist painted by Tony Bennett it is
impossible not to be touched by the
aspiration visible wherever you look
this it is clear was the home of a
working man bursting with a pride that
came not from what he had but what he
did I never want to be anything more
than I am what I don't have
I don't need Armstrong said in his old
age my home is good but you don't see me
in no big estates and yachts that ain't
going to play your horn for you in
common with other self-made men
Armstrong sometimes forgot that his
success was due not solely to work and
pluck but also to the talent with which
he had been born he was a man of
boundless generosity who preached the
Stoney gospel of individual
responsibility a ferociously ambitious
artist who preferred when he could to do
as he was told an introspective man who
exploded with irrepressible vitality
when he stepped into this
light a joyous genius who confounded his
critics by refusing to distinguish
between making art and making fun no
more than any other genius was he all of
the piece as Murray Kempton said he
endures to mix in his own person all men
the pure in the cheap clown and creator
God in buffoon yet all was resolved each
time he raised his trumpet to his lips
for that was when the laughter stopped
and the beauty began he knew that in his
words showmanship does not mean you're
not serious and no one who has read his
writings can doubt that he was both
serious and self-aware he knew who he
was
what he had done and how far he had come
and was fiercely proud of it all he
admitted that his music mattered more to
him than anything else even his wives
when I pick up that horn he said that's
all the world's behind me and I don't
concentrate on nothing but it that my
living in my life I love them notes that
way I try to make him write see the
whole world saw and heard so that's how
my book starts and now if you don't mind
a few words of epilogue I spent five
years working on pops especially in the
past few months a great many people have
asked me something like this that's a
lot of time to spend with anybody do you
still like Armstrong do you still admire
him or did you get sick and tired of him
as an easy question to answer I didn't
get sick or tired of Louis Armstrong I
don't see how you could is that rarity
of rarities a great man who improves
with exposure the better you get to know
him the more you like him this isn't to
say that he wasn't a complicated
personality because he was very much so
offstage he could be Moody and profaned
he had a habit of flying into red rages
that he forgot all about the next day
and he knew how to hold a grudge I got a
simple rule about everybody he told the
journalist if you don't treat me right
shame on you but that's merely to say
that arms
as a human being as flawed as the next
man and if there's anything that I
learned in the process of writing Pop's
it is that Louis Armstrong's flaws were
few and forgivable in return for his
unswerving dedication to his art he knew
true happiness and shared it
unstintingly with his fellow men not
long before he died he told a friend
that my whole life has been happiness
through all the misfortunes etc I did
not plan anything life was there for me
and I accepted it in life whatever came
out has been beautiful to me and I love
everybody I can't top that so I'll let
pops have the last word
well now the floor is yours I would be
more than happy to answer any questions
that you might have about Louis
Armstrong or about my book if you'll
make your way to the microphone I'll do
my best questions and thanks so much for
doing the book one is in terms of his
early life there's a book called Louis
Armstrong's in New Orleans it's sort of
a set in context what what did you bring
new information Lee about his early life
that we don't have from other books not
that's one in the second how did he
react to all the criticism that he got
from other jazz musicians sort of in the
younger newer wave and the 60s you know
the and who didn't like his you know
sort of what they viewed as some Uncle
Tom ISM of the stage act how did he
react to that a whole bunch of questions
there
Thomas Brothers Louis Armstrong's New
Orleans is the most important scholarly
monograph ever written about Armstrong
it is a thorough inspection strong early
years I think beyond what brothers did
which was to look at all the existing
onsite primary sources in New Orleans
and he was able to do this before
Hurricane Katrina what I bring to it is
not new factual information about
Armstrong's younger years because
they're pretty well worked over as far
as the facts go
but maybe a different perhaps a wider
cultural perspective to set them in a
larger frame and particularly the frame
of someone who has been a working jazz
musician that I think is one of the most
important things about my book beyond
the fact that I had access to
Armstrong's private tapes and lots of
other sources that come later in his
life is the fact that that I was in
business that I actually know what it's
like to as I was telling somebody the
other day to play in one of those broken
bottle joints where they have chicken
wire in front of the bandstand I think I
think maybe my book is informed by this
experience in a way that previous books
that Armstrong has not been the second
question that you ask is a major theme
of my book discussed in great detail
there and I can only talk about it in a
very compressed way here but when
talking about this you always have to
remember that Louis Armstrong was born
in 1901 he seems contemporary to us
because he is so completely vivid and
present in his films and because there
is so much film of him and for those of
us over the age of 50
we remember seeing him on television I
first saw him on The Ed Sullivan Show
one Sunday night when I was 8 years old
thank you very much and because he seems
contemporary to us we expect him to be
contemporary in a way that he's not he
wasn't
was born in 1901 in the deep south his
whole formative experience as a musician
in a stage entertainer is formed by the
world of vaudeville and also the world
of the minstrel show and what he thought
was funny and I might add what his
contemporaries thought was funny black
and white alike was something that the
younger musicians of the post-world War
2 era the bebop era did not find funny
they felt uncomfortable about it and
they criticized him about it Dizzy
Gillespie most prominently and I think
most sharply I think they just didn't
take him in historical perspective and
some of them lived long enough to change
their tune including I'm happy to say
Dizzy Gillespie who in his autobiography
written at the end of his life
apologized to Armstrong for having
described him as an uncle
Tom in fact I will quote Gillespie
verbatim because these words have stuck
in my mind he said hell I had my own way
of timing so I think now that we are as
far beyond Armstrong's life as Gillespie
was beyond the beginnings of it we can
see him as he was as a figure from
history and as someone who's art and I
think whose personality is of permanent
interest in permanently contemporary
even if there are aspects of it that we
wouldn't especially want to see at the
movies today let us say insurance great
work now yes sir thank you for your talk
thanks for this lovely book I imagine
for a serious critic like yourself it's
hard to sustain focus on and produce an
objective book on a subject that is so
utterly loveable and who you obviously
loved and you pulled it off so well I
mean I don't pretend to be visted
objectivity sounds you know like
something that came out of the icebox
and there's a sense in which I'm not an
even slightly objective about Louis
Armstrong it was a great man but I tried
to write as a scholar would write and
you know to to do what he said on more
than one occasion he would want a
biographer to do which was to tell the
whole story of his life to tell them
well this book is scholarly and it is
warm so it's very nice so I'm going to
ask you a very specific question because
it's so thoroughly agreeable you really
have to work to find like a disagreement
about a choice of composition or
something I'll ask you that and it has
to do about latter day Armstrong and you
can answer it and perhaps talk a little
bit about Louis the last decade or so in
how creative he was and the charges that
you're familiar with them that last
decade of him as a musician in this book
you refer to the real ambassadors as too
earnest for its own good
yeah that's for everybody who doesn't
know the album it's a musical that Dave
and I own a Brubeck wrote in which it
was only done on record and Armstrong
appears in it performs in it in my
opinion now they say I love I look like
God is one of those beautiful well that
he says ever done beautiful son on race
relations it's just you know he was
supposedly interiors at the end of it
and and of course one of the
some real ambassadors is in my appendix
of my 30 favorite Armstrong I'm
recording summer song which is also
beautiful but there's a whole bunch of
other jamming songs in so anyways you
you make that remark if you've been
comment on that but just comment on that
last decade and whether maybe his
creativity was limited by the fact that
he was working all these years of the
Joe Glaser who may not have been as
plugged into tapping artists I'm trying
to genius until the end let's let's talk
a little bit about that Joe Glaser was
Armstrong's manager from 1935 until
blazars death about a year and a half
before Armstrong died Glaser was to a
great extent responsible for bringing
Armstrong to a wider popular audience
but as I say repeatedly in my book
people who knew Armstrong who knew
Glaser who played with Armstrong who
worked in blazers office they all said
the same thing which was that Armstrong
went where Glaser told him to go but
when he got there he played what he
wanted to play Armstrong is not a man
who really thinks of himself in a
self-conscious way as an artist and he
knew he was an artist on only one
occasion did I ever find him talking
about how jazz was art that's in the
book but he knew what he was but he
thought of himself as an entertainer and
he didn't think there was anything
incompatible between being an artist and
being an entertainer and I think he got
as much pleasure out of making people
laugh as he did thrilling them and I say
this somewhere in the book we must take
great artists as they were rather than
imagining what we wish they were and
tried to take them that way instead the
music that Armstrong record in the last
10 years of his life is spottier than
the music you recorded in the 20s or 30s
but the high points are as high as
anything that he did at any time in his
life summer song with Brubeck the
amazing recording of Black and Tans
fantasy that he made was Duke Ellington
and it was 61 and let us say it Hello
Dolly which is a great pop record but
also a great jazz record it really is
you know I think I wouldn't want if it
were left up to me
I wouldn't want only to have the music
of the last ten years of Armstrong's
life to listen to but if that's all I
had I'd take it and be glad who's who's
up next I just have a quick question
yeah
you spoke about the five or six hundred
tapes that he made at any time is Louis
Armstrong's home in New York a library
at this pointer is it open to the pilot
glad you asked me that not only is it a
museum but I'm speaking there on
Saturday they're throwing a book party
for me and I'm going to give a shorter
version of this talk in Armstrong's own
home it was opened up it was restored to
its original condition a few years ago
and opened as a museum and I must tell
you that if you have the slightest
interest in Louis Armstrong you must go
to this place because the walls breathe
his essence it is one of the most
amazing house museums in the world thank
God that it was preserved and and is the
way it is so I'll be thinking of you all
on Saturday afternoon when I when I go
there and speak there all the tapes okay
there are 650 reel-to-reel tapes
Armstrong I'll tell you the whole story
Armstrong bought one of the first
commercial tape recorders ever sold in
the United States in 1947 and Bing
Crosby bought one of the others by the
way and at first he bought it to record
his shows so that he could listen to
them and perfect them a reminder that
Armstrong is in fact a true artist and
self aware artist but like everybody
else who first got their hands on a tape
recorder when tape recorders renew he
started playing with it and pretty soon
he figured out that he could just turn
it on backstage in the dressing room or
in his hotel room or or wherever and let
it run and he saved the tapes they were
stored in the attic of the house they
made their way into the Armstrong
archives I was the first biographer to
get to listen to them and now I will
tell you a story about one of them
because I think it exemplifies what they
tell us they tell us important facts
there's one type where Armstrong talks
about his run-in with the mobsters in
Chicago and names name
something he didn't do anywhere else but
some of the tapes are just fun so I
mentioned this in passing in the talk
but I'll tell you a little bit more
about it there is a tape my guess is
that it was recorded sometime in the 50s
in a hotel room somewhere in the world I
have no idea where it's 5:00 in the
morning Louis Armstrong is trying to get
his wife Lucille to go to bed with him
and she's really not interested in this
at 5:00 in the morning and declines with
thanks and he says well it's your duty
to do that it's your duty to keep the
horn percolating well this didn't amuse
her one bit and then she looks around
and you can almost hear the double take
on the tape she sees the tape recorder
is running and she says to him you turn
that off in fact you erase off some of
that stuff and he says I can't do that
this is for posterity okay alright flash
forward 50 years Here I am you know that
the scholar with the headphones on
sitting in the Armstrong archives at
Queens College and I'm listening to this
tape and suddenly it hits me my god I'm
posterity he saved it for me and he he
saved it for all of us because he knew
that he was after all Louis Armstrong
and he wanted us to know what he was
like and those tapes tell us that better
than anything other than his art can
possibly tell us yes sir
congratulations on your nomination for
the n-double-a-cp
I'm very proud um to sort of piggyback
on that that theme could you really I
guess share with us the true impact of
what he did for race relations in the
United States yes I liked very much like
to talk about I guess my next question
is how did he really grapple with the
criticism because one of his other
admirers is Ralph Ellison you know
during the late 60s when he was being
criticized along with Louis Armstrong he
really um really took it bad when you
know the black Nash was really tolling
he was on the job well I mean
essentially Armstrong grappled with the
criticism by living his life I mean
occasionally he would he would try to
set the record straight and talk about
the things he had done but he didn't
lose a whole lot of sleep over what
people said about him even though he
didn't
like it he wasn't the kind of man to
lose a whole lot of sleep about anything
that anybody said about him now as far
as what he contributed to race relations
I think I can answer that question best
by telling a story I come from a town in
southeast Missouri
it's called Saxton none of you will have
heard of it
my father witnessed a lynching it was
that kind of town Louis Armstrong was
probably excuse me for many people in
that town Louis Armstrong was probably
the first black person I ever took
seriously as an artist as a man and I
think that by reaching out through his
art and his personality he bridged gaps
then no one else could have bridged
either I'm been affected by this and
that
I think meant as much I talked about
this in in less personal terms in the
book but I think that that is meant as
much to the public at large in the 50s
and 60s as was as much of a contribution
to racial justice and racial relations
as anything that anybody was doing at
that time simply by his own personal
example that's the best way I can answer
that question and I saw that at first
hand heavily other questions the
microphone awaits you and so do I but if
I we have somebody is rising to go to
the microphone so I'll give you a minute
there while I recapture my composure I
do you address in the book his standing
as a jazz icon of the black community
with black Americans versus white is
there a difference I mean where does his
standing is huge with white Americans of
area I know that but is his is he
considered like the pinnacle what he is
now
yeah but I never thought look part of
what my book is is what scholars call a
reception history which is an attempt to
try to describe how Armstrong was
written about and how people responded
to him throughout the course of his
career and like every other jazz
musician Armstrong ceased to a great
extent to be popular in the black
community because it lost interest in
jazz is a community it's really troubled
him there's a funny story I tell in the
book which I really can't repeat here
about his going to a gig by Louie Jordan
and his was halfway empty and he just
couldn't believe what had happened Miles
Davis talked the same way in the 60s
about how how the racial composition of
jazz audiences had changed and yes he
was troubled by it on the other hand
again jazz is now a historical music a
historical event rather than a popular
music and
I think that nowadays pretty much
everybody sees Armstrong in the same way
as the central figure in the history of
jazz in the 20th century there's no
racial differential there he's is
important to everybody who cares about
jazz no matter who they are that's
something that I would say has happened
in the last quarter century there are a
lot of factors that have to do that the
advocacy of Wynton Marsalis has been a
very important part of making
Armstrong's achievement known especially
to younger people but part of it is just
that jazz is now itself the 20th century
jazz the 20th century is over and we
look upon it as a closed event and we
know how important Armstrong was that's
the best way I can answer your question
jazz clubs in New York and Lee but maybe
that's a very small well New York is
only a very small part of the audience
for jazz thank heavens yes I hear there
are jazz clubs in Washington as well I
want to ask you about your other writing
especially your writing in The Wall
Street Journal which I read I'm sure
other people read your columns and what
your sense of your sensibility and
sensitivity and writing for the journal
brings not to a wider public audience
but to the audience and people who read
those kinds of writings in the
publication that is perhaps growing and
influenced for the kinds of things that
you're bringing or whether you feel that
way or not I don't know how to answer
that I don't really I don't really think
about it that way I mean how I think of
myself what I do I am a specialist who
trance tries to translate the knowledge
of a specialist into generalist language
I mean I can and have in the past done
so written for scholarly audiences but
I'm not really interested in doing that
I'm interested in taking what I know
about the arts and I do write about all
the arts and I'm not just jazz not just
drama and and try to communicate this
knowledge to try to be a teacher and
also maybe above all is a critic to try
to communicate enthusiasm because I
think that is the
important thing that a credit can do I
mean the biggest thing that critic does
is to say I saw this and you should too
and to be persuasive about it and for me
to be able to do that in the Wall Street
Journal which is now the daily paper
with the largest circulation in the
United States well that's a big deal
it's a big responsibility and I feel
that responsibility some of you know
that in addition to covering theatres in
New York I cover theatres all over the
United States including in this city and
I'm very committed to that half of my
reviews are outside New York and one of
the reasons why I do that is because I
know I'm writing for a national
newspaper that has a national audience
that part I take really seriously
whatever the character of The Wall
Street Journal's readers is I don't
really know what that is I think they're
pretty much all over the map I guarantee
you they're not all rich I'm not rich
but it's a paper with a big a big
readership and therefore it's a big
pulpit and I try to use it in the best
way that I can thank you
Andhra Shahrukh